[Música]
uma boa noite a todos
eu venho de uma família tradicional
criada na vossa sua cabecinha ou pelo
menos ruim até aos 12 anos de idade onde
quando eu chorava
eu ouvia com esse valor é o mesmo fora
se eu queria brincar com a boneca da
minha irmã é coisa de de bola isso vive
boa parte da infância também ótima na
roça as crianças são mais livres e eu
com toda a liberdade da roça corria no
meio dos pasta debaixo de chuva como um
potrinho novo quando chove
com 12 anos de uma família de seis
irmãos o sonho do meu pai e meus filhos
deveriam ter uma vida melhor
constrangidos própria diferia de uma
cidade grande onde eu vivi a minha
adolescência e à minha juventude
hoje sei que sou querido zé porque eu
passei os olhos nesse período os tempos
da ditadura militar
sequelas nesse período os concelhos com
os moradores davam
dessa forma fica triste mas tudo isso
também como eu vivi numa mesma época a
minha alma minha juventude numa época
onde era proibido de pensar fez com que
as amizades são proximais internalizados
fossem mais puras porque a gente não
podia pensar em que jogava no braço do
outro
hoje eu me reúno com um grupo de colegas
de escolas que são amigos que a gente se
conhece há mais de 40 anos
vamos aqui possa podem fazer isso então
é um privilégio que eu tenho e nesse
período eu vivi até aos 28 anos quando
eu me casei para eu ter uma sorte danada
fazer uma uma mulher maravilhosa
dez anos mais nova que eu e vivemos os
melhores momentos da minha vida
temos dois filhos biológicos lindos e
maravilhosos 1 com o oposto do outro o
mais velho lucas era história 14 uso de
uma presença muito grande quando ele
quando ele chegava todo mundo sabia
lucas chegou público mais novo mais
sensível quando ele saía todo mundo
estava saindo
o documento chama de novo álbum coisa de
velho definir os dois formavam a dupla
linda se amava muito porque o abraço que
eu não pude receber do meu pai
uma ação que eu tive eu passei a buscar
dos meus filhos
nós tivemos eu e os dois mãe força junto
ea vida foi levando muito só felicidade
até que um dia eu como bom flamenguista
na br1 uma transmissão na televisão na
época meu flamengo paga ninguém
eu deitar na cama assistindo televisão
meu filho mais velho com 16 anos chegou
pra mim e bom pai
nós precisamos ter uma conversa de uma
prova foi como é que é não é fácil
manter uma conversa de aumentar ó então
vamos ter essa conversa
raúl como o machismo arraigado trazido
de longas datas
com essa meta
ele vira pra mim para eu sou e
pai você ouviu eu sou e
naquele momento tudo passou na minha
cabeça
primeiro a cobrança da sociedade
hipócrita que eu vou criar e que exigia
que eu quem nasce com um órgão masculino
entre as feras não pode jogar tem de ser
machão tem que ser o cara não tem seu
pegador e meu filho não era isso foi um
choque
na verdade a gente não sabia mas
procurava acreditar que não
mas aí começa a se instalar ou um
processo que só foi possível porque nós
tivemos uma infância junto porque eu
tive liberdade cid na minha infância e
aprendida libertar dá valor à liberdade
e aprendi a respeitar as pessoas contou
surpresa a uma ditadura militar
nisso tudo o que pesou pesou amor com eu
tinha criado meus filhos com o passar do
tempo ea coisa que nesse momento mais me
tocou e me deixou feliz e mudou a minha
vida
a banda meu filho olhando pegando no meu
rosto
olhou pra mim dentro do gol ele falou
'pai eu sou homossexual
eu sou gay mas podem passar mil homens
da minha vida mas o único homem que eu
vou amar de verdade é você
aí eu pude perceber que o meu filho não
era aquilo que a sociedade queria essa
sociedade cobrando que ele fosse mas foi
talvez o maior ser humano um homem que
conhecia a partir desse momento eu
passei aceitar meu filho do jeito que
ele era e isso possibilitou com que
atacar daquela dentada na cama junto
comigo
ele se levantou uma pessoa completamente
diferente
era uma pessoa extremamente alegre mas
não era feliz porque ele não era ele que
a partir desse momento com a felicidade
estampada no rosto quando vão pagar
aquele tinha 16 anos de aniversário por
sabe o curso de jornalismo na
universidade federal de goiás passou
também essa é outra pessoa como
militante pela causa lgbt militante com
pela liberdade dos a gbt sem esquecer
que eles são serão livres para amar da
forma que quiser ea quem quiser
nessa luta que se criou um símbolo e até
hoje o roda por todo o lado como sendo a
marca dele numa actividade acontecido
numa universidade em brasília
a reitoria é exigiu uma atividade no
congresso lgbt
a reitora exigiu que se separasse os
alojamentos das meninas e dos meninos e
ele indignado não aceitou e pro cachorro
o protesto beijo 8
a partir daquele momento ele colocou uma
saia para simbolizar a sua indignação
contra a violência de venda hoje a sair
agora por tudo quanto é canto
em memória dele e ele continua militando
mas ela não era um cara de sorte tinha
do lado dele a mãe que militava com ele
o tempo todo e em todas as movimentações
que ia ela usava essa bóia apanhava de
defender seus direitos dentro da
universidade
ele criou um grupo chamado conferir
etário com eles identificavam e eles
construíram uma mão
essa bandeira
essa bandeira do grupo que criou
mas quis o destino estilo fabricar por
essa sociedade que no dia 18 de novembro
de 2012 quando o meu filho se encontrava
a trabalho em cabo de santo agostinho
grande recife capital os jogos da do
campeonato brasileiro de vôlei
cadeirante foi acertada
uma noite ela saiu da pousada pra é e
comprar um cigarro foi encontrado na
manhã seguinte boiando no mar
ele podia lentamente espancado e jogado
ainda com vida no mar com a morte dele é
uma dor tremenda a dizer memória da
história dele da luta dele da mãe o
advogado na nota
sabendo que sair da minha zona de
conforto
porque eu acredito que a luta deles era
uma luta importante uma luta essencial
pelos direitos humanos na luta porque eu
não queria eu não quero que o pai tenha
que cumprir a mesma missão que eu contei
o que eu tive que cumprir de recolher
meu filho tenha enterrado em um caixão
lacrado
hoje eu enquanto essa luta porque também
encontrei a minha mesma coisa também
hoje eu faço parte do coletivo mães pela
diversidade com os inglês que me acolheu
e me deu oportunidade de ver alguns
conhecimentos para entender mais a luta
lgbt e buscar tirar os quais do armário
porque é mais difícil para o país sair
do armário
com ele porque eu tenho consciência que
o pai que não sai do armário
ele é o responsável pela assinatura não
é fato derrota do filho hoje ponto
coletivo mas pela velocidade vai falhar
propósito do brasil infelizmente aqui em
joão pessoa nós não temos uma
coordenação mas com certeza teremos e em
memória da minha esposa e meu filho é
questões à volta porque o que nós éramos
uma família e decidimos que a tristeza
da nossa vida para partilhar a alegria
eo amor e hoje eu só lembro alegria que
foi ter convivido com os dois por 28
anos
eu sou um privilegiado por isso ele
considera um privilegiado por isso não
me vejo fora dessa luta não tem o
direito de ficar fora dessa luta porque
o tempo e eu acredito piamente a morte
de meu filho não foi bom não pode ter
sido em volta dele morreu
[Música]
mas ele generosamente me deixou milhões
de milhões de filhos lgbts precisa de um
pouco de carinho e precisa ser aceito
principalmente pela família e onde
começa a aprender a apreciar a primeira
violência recebido no ct e hoje eu estou
aqui para compartilhar essa história é
uma história que eu pretendo transformar
um grande amor
muito obrigado a todos
[Aplausos]